Alaskan Bush People is about a large family
struggling to live off the land in—you guessed
it—Alaska.
But the Brown family may not be struggling
as much as you might think.
Here's the real truth about the show...and
the family behind it.
BORN RICH
Billy Bryan Brown admits in his own writing
that he wasn't born in Alaska.
He claims to have been born into "a world
of privilege" to a Texas limo company president.
In his words: "I was given new boats and cars
for my birthdays.
I was truly the luckiest kid in town—I had
it all—money, clothes, big ticket toys and
a loving family, too."
Sadly, Brown's parents perished in a plane
crash in 1969, after which Brown says he did
odd jobs around Texas and New Mexico to make
ends meet.
TEEN BRIDE
Radar Online reports that Ami Brown was only
15 years old when she married Billy Bryan
Brown in 1979.
Billy was 26, accounting for an 11 year age
gap.
That's illegal in most states today.
And creepy everywhere, always.
PROBABLY RICHER THAN THEY LOOK
While the family's exact net worth is difficult
to determine without examining their tax returns,
it's safe to assume they're not as poor as
they want us to believe.
Why?
Well, for one thing, they get paid to be on
television, a deal that's usually at least
kind of lucrative for the participants—no
matter what bushes they like to live in.
BILLY BRYAN BROWN: ACCOMPLISHED WRITER
The family patriarch has over 70 books under
his belt, one of which, One Wave At A Time,
actually inspired the television show.
That's impressive for someone who, ostensibly,
has never used anything beyond candlelight
and fountain pen to write, let alone a typewriter,
computer, or the Internet.
Speaking of…
THE KIDS USE TECHNOLOGY
In 2008, Gabriel Brown (wearing a tank top)
posted a YouTube video about his life.
He talks about his father's book tour and
a potential movie deal stemming from One Wave
At A Time.
He says it's the first time any of the kids
have been out of the wilderness, "the first
time we've ever seen a traffic jam," or eaten
fast food.
He says that they'll post videos for the duration
of the tour, which is an odd activity if they're
not skilled in technology.
He ends the video with impersonations of celebrities…the
same celebrities that he'd never have known
about if he didn't have access to television
or the Internet.
Huh?
THE BROWNS MAY HAVE TO LEAVE THE BUSH
Ami Brown suffers from cervical radiculitis,
a form of arthritis in her neck.
She told Radar Online, "It's just something
I think I'm going to have to live with…It
limits me on things that I can do that I like
to do and enjoy to do.
It definitely makes it harder to live there.
It's sad and true."
Meanwhile, Billy Bryan Brown's struggles with
seizures have been documented on the show:
if they continue, he'll have to stop pretending
to live like a barbarian for a while and spend
more time closer to hospitals.
THEY KNOW HOW TO PARTY
Matt Brown was arrested in 2013 for DUI after
what Radar Online describes as a night of
some pretty hard partying.
He was pulled over for driving drunk and hitting
a parked car in a Walmart parking lot at 4:45
in the morning, after which he "very animatedly"
told his arresting officer about hooking up
with a girl named Julie in a nearby bar.
He was sentenced to three days in jail and
18 months of probation.
No word on whether or not Julie ever called
him back, though.
THEY MIGHT BE FRAUDSTERS
Billy Bryan Brown was charged with 24 counts
of unsworn falsification and theft in January
2016, while Radar Online reports that Ami
and sons Solomon and Gabe each were charged
with eight counts.
Sons Noah and Josh also faced six counts each.
ABC News reports that Brown allegedly lied
on official government applications regarding
their Alaskan residency in order to receive
Permanent Fund dividend checks from the state.
Billy and son Josh pleaded guilty and were
each sentenced to 30 days in jail.
The family was ordered to pay $21,000 in restitution
to the state of Alaska.
In an official statement on the case, Billy
Brown said, "Alaska's dividend program has
specific requirements for the length of time
in the state, and the reasons for being out
of Alaska.
Because of the way we live our lives and the
way we often unconventionally travel, I didn't
keep good track of our movements.
I accept full responsibility for filing for
benefits without confirming that we met the
requirements…We are committed to living
in Alaska for the long term and we respect
the state's rules.
I thought it best to settle to put this behind
us."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.